[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir nous avons inauguré la
plateforme de financement synapses qui
est une plateforme territoriale de
financement dédié aux territoires paris
saclay alors pourquoi territoriales
parce que c'est d'abord ça elle permet
de habitants et monsieur sage et du
territoire de financer en ligne à
travers un prêt ou un investissement des
entreprises qui ont un lien avec avec
paris saclay territoriale aussi parce
qu'elle repose sur un partenariat de
l'ensemble des acteurs du territoire qui
sont engagés dans la recherche dans
l'innovation dans l'accompagnement des
entreprises la création d'entreprise et
dans le financement et qui aident senti
que le capital qui est à l'initiative de
ce projet à constituer une communauté de
financeurs à instruire les projets à les
suivre à les accompagner pourront faire
vivre cette plateforme est enfin
territoriales parce qu'elle a pour
ambition d'être la vitrine technologique
de toute la technologie développée sur
le territoire de paris saclay qui comme
on le sait une technologie haut de gamme
avec une forte portée internationale
[Musique]
ce qu'on espère c'est que les
technologies développées dans lesdites
tech
c'est à dire des technologies
donc profondes avec des phases de r&d
longue attirant
bientôt les investisseurs internationaux
et que la plateforme synapses sera le
lieu où les startups deep tech en
recherche de financement pourront être
présentées et financer
[Musique]